Text graphics appear: Publishing your app on Google Play is just the beginning
The Google Play Console logo appears on the screen
The Google Play Control Panel appears on the screen
Text Appears: Increase app quality Get better ratings
An overview of "Android dynamic cursors" appears on the screen
Maximize drop-down menu within Google Play
A test release report appears on the screen
Graphics with text: Netflix enabled robots to reduce crashes by 70% in 3 months
Figure 1 with text: Cook Craze reduced the 21%
Figure 2 which has text: Erudite application reduced the number of errors and good retention rate by 60%
On the Control Panel screen, "Device List"
Text Appearance: Manage versions easily
Drawing by text: Drupe no crashes The usage rate was improved to 99.7%
Drawing by text: Omnidrone increased user interaction by more than 50% and profits by more than 20%
The Acquisition Report control panel appears on the screen.
Text Appears: Understand your audience's retention rate improvement
Examples of views and ratings appear on mobile
Text App: Aviary provides 5-10 hours per week through ratings and opinions
The "Store listing experiment" dashboard appears on the screen.
Text Appears: Increase the number of installs for your app
Text with text: Hashcube increased the number of installations by 88%
Text: Papumba downloads have increased by 30% in 12 months, translating into 15 languages
The Overview panel appears in the Google Play Console screen
Text Appears: Earn More Profits
Drawing by text: The game Bombsquad has increased average profit per user by 140%
Fee by text: Viki company increased the profits of subscriptions by 200%
The Google Play Console control panel appears. Text appearance: Get support
The chat box appears with the help team staff
Text: Start at g.co/play/console
Google Play Console logo